what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and marbles phase five and phase six has
definitely changed since the
announcement of phase five and some of
phase six at San Diego Comic-Con that's
last year's 2022 San Diego Comic-Con
Marvel Studios unfortunately will not be
attending Hall h this year as well as a
lot of other people who normally attend
as well so sadly we aren't getting any
huge reveals from Marvel anytime soon
and we're not going to be getting any
updates because they're not attending
sdcc which is unfortunate because fans
want to know what exactly is going on
Marvel Studios has delayed some projects
they are even thinking about canceling
some projects According to some insiders
but luckily for us Deadpool 3 actually
got pushed forward and we got our first
look at Hugh Jackman's Wolverine today
in his classic comic accurate yellow
suit so if you didn't check out that
video we did yet be sure to check it out
but today we'll focus on a phase 5 and
Phase 6 update since a lot of things
have happened since the last time they
have announced any type of schedule
which of course is probably going to be
changing in the future as well this is
due to the rider strike and further
strikes that might take place in the
future that could prevent actors from
working as well so we'll give you the
most recent updates we've heard about
Marvel Studios as Phase 5 and phase six
so if you want to stay up to date on the
MCU be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
also if you want to enter our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items be sure
to subscribe and leave a comment down
below to enter the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month now like I've
mentioned the first half of Marvel's
Phase 5 has not been delayed and in fact
Deadpool even got pushed up so this is
great news the Marvel's AKA Captain
Marvel 2 is still set for November 10th
of 2023 this year and that will be the
last Marvel movie of 2023 but fear not
we still have two more Disney Plus shows
coming out this year as well and of
course we are at the halfway point of
secret Invasion right now Loki season 2
is coming this year and the great news
is it is still set for the same release
date October 6th of this year it has not
been pushed back in fact almost a week
ago Disney put out a press release in
regards to Loki's season 2. and
thankfully in this press release it's
still listed Loki for this same date
which tells us everything is still going
according to plan with Loki season 2.
despite everything that has been going
on with Jonathan Majors but something
that is very interesting about the press
release that was sent out to the Press
is that it still stated Jonathan Majors
as a part of the cast it even said with
Jonathan majors and when they typically
list a cast and then say with a certain
actor it usually means because they are
holding them at some type of prestige so
it looks like things are still going
according to plan for Loki season 2.
which is great to see from Disney
because right now they are probably
waiting to see what they're going to do
with Jonathan Majors it all really
depends on what the court decision is so
it doesn't look like Loki season 2 is
going to change so expect that on
October 6 and then immediately after
we're going to get the echo series on
November 29th which is going to be
released all at once bin style and
something that is really interesting
that we've heard about this from some
insiders is that Disney was planning on
batgirling this project meaning they had
made it but they were going to cancel it
and not show it now clearly they are not
canceling it since they are releasing it
in November but they are releasing it
binge style which means that it's very
possible that they might have had talks
about canceling this however I would
like to add that several insiders
including Casey Walsh has said that they
have heard this show is good and we've
heard that from more than one Insider so
there could be a lot of determining
factors into them possibly wanting to
cancel the series but it is official it
is going to be coming out officially
being the last Marvel project of 2023
and then the first movie that is going
to greet Us in 2024 is Deadpool 3 and
luckily for us this has moved up from
its original release date it's been
moved up from November 8th of 2024 to
May 3rd of 2024. so again luckily for us
the first part of Phase 5 hasn't been
delayed and Deadpool got moved up so the
Marvel's Loki season 2 and Echo are
still the same however the next part of
Phase 5 has been delayed unfortunately
you may have heard that Captain America
4 Brave New World the Thunderbolts and
blade have been delayed we'll go over
this quickly so we can dive into phase
six but Captain America Brave New World
has been pushed back to July 26th of
2024 the Thunderbolts have been pushed
back to December 20th of 2024 and blade
has been pushed back to February 14th of
2025. now originally blade was supposed
to be coming out before the Thunderbolts
and Captain America so we are still
grouping this with phase five phase six
has not yet started but as far as the
phase 5 Disney Plus shows are concerned
we do not have official release dates
for them yet but we do have the year
that they are are supposed to come out
in for most of them that is ironheart is
supposed to come out in 2024 Agatha
Covenant of Chaos in 2024 as well and
Daredevil born again is supposed to come
out early 2024. however there are shows
like what if season 2 that don't even
have a year associated with them yet and
of course if we hear anything we'll be
sure to do an update but phase six is
where it gets really interesting
especially if you consider some
developments that have happened recently
in the Marvel Universe we have two new
confirmed projects coming in phase six
and we believe we know the order which
means we now have six confirmed projects
coming in phase six and actually more if
we consider some of the things that
Marvel Studios has told us before and
what some insiders are stating as well
now the original phase six slate that
they showed us at San Diego Comic-Con
last year showed us 11 slots with only
three of them being revealed the
Fantastic Four Avengers King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars and again Marvel
Studios probably didn't plan on
revealing any of phase six however the
day before San Diego Comic-Con both
titles Avengers the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars got leaked so since
they got leaked Marvel Studios might
have just decided to go ahead and tease
us with three projects from phase six
since we pretty much already knew what
they were and now we can confirm some
projects and fill in a lot of these
other slots so on top of the Fantastic
Four and the two Avengers films we're
also going to get doctor strange 3. and
recently Benedict Cumberbatch on a show
confirmed he is filming something for
Doctor Strange next year confirming his
comeback and confirming whatever he's
filming will take place before the Kang
Dynasty and this makes perfect sense
he's going to have a big role to play
with incursions and in the post-credits
scene for Multiverse of Madness Clea
found him and stated he caused an
incursion and they had to go fix it and
he was ready to go so no doubt they
gotta tell us that story before the King
Dynasty now SEMA Liu also recently this
week came out and confirmed Xiang Chi 2
is happening and he confirmed that it
supposed to happen after the King
Dynasty and this will fit perfectly The
Avengers are going to go up against Kang
in the King Dynasty and after these
events they're going to have a lot to
deal with and they will most likely lose
so after the battle they have to come
together once again to figure out how to
defeat him down the road and no doubt
that the 10 rings are going to be a big
factor in the fight against Kang in the
Kang Dynasty but then after as well
diving deeper into the Ring's Origins
because remember they never really told
us where winwoo got the Rings in the
first young Chief film and then of
course coming before the King Dynasty is
going to be Spider-Man 4. Tom Holland
has spoken up recently and he has
confirmed he has met with Marvel Studios
and Sony and they have already begun
talking about Spider-Man 4 and have been
talking specifically about the story so
if anybody was wondering or perhaps a
little bit nervous that Tom Holland
wouldn't return He is it is confirmed
it's also worth mentioning that Sony did
confirm a live-action Miles Morales
movie is in the works as well very very
early pre-development but they are
working on it and we are not sure if
this will be an MCU Spider-Man film or
if it's simply going to just exist in
the Sony spider-verse of course if we
hear anything we'll be sure to update
then to top that off we do have Marvel
Studios projects that are confirmed but
we simply don't know where they fall for
example armor Wars armor Wars was once
scheduled to be a Disney plus series and
is now a movie this pushed it back a
little bit and right now is to be
determined but it looks like this is
going to fall in phase six somewhere
that makes seven confirmed projects then
we have Wonder Man which is confirmed by
Marvel Studios and the casting is
actually confirmed Yaya Abdul Mateen II
will be playing Wonder Man so that is
eight confirmed projects then we have
the eternals 2. that was definitely set
up and the events that happened in the
first eternals film definitely have to
be addressed we can't just ignore
celestials and the Judgment of
celestials that is definitely coming
back to play in the MCU so that makes
nine then we have World War Hulk this is
confirmed by but we actually really
don't know when this is going to come
out it could come out in phase six or
they could save it till after Secret
Wars were unsure but what do you think
they should do let us know down below
then we have the rumored Nova series now
this isn't confirmed so we're not going
to count this one but several insiders
especially over from thecosmiccircus.com
have stated that a Nova special
presentation is coming from Marvel
Studios now we do know that a wakanda
series from Ryan coogler on Disney plus
is going to be coming so that would
technically be 10. we won't count World
War Hulk or Nova since it's not
confirmed where they exactly will take
place in the MCU Phase 6 or phase seven
but with the confirmed wakanda series
that puts us at 10 out of the 11 slots
and hopefully Marvel Studios has a
pretty decent surprise for us for that
11 slot maybe it could be Hulk maybe it
could be Nova maybe it could be
something completely different maybe the
X-Men could show up before phase seven
who knows but I hope it's a good
surprise and this is where we're at
currently for Phase 5 and phase six now
like I mentioned there could be some
more delay coming and it looks like
Marvel Studios might even be considering
canceling some shows or perhaps pushing
them back to phase 7 or Beyond but of
course if anything changes or we get any
type of an update we'll be sure to do an
update video so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you want to further support the
channel you can check out our patreon
account our Discord server and our
website you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign